[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the incredible
showdown currently taking place in the
seminal listen story the last few arcs
have built up to this fight so perfectly
that it can be easy to assume that this
will be the final epic battle in the
entire seven deadly sins series and
while this is definitely possible in
this video I will examine all the
evidence as to why I think that this
might not be the final battle after all
and why I think that there is still more
seven deadly sins action to come if you
enjoy these videos you can either like
to let me know and if you're new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell before we
get into it pro manga artist Cuusoo mati
has created an exclusive new shirt
design for our online store demon king
meliodas
all hail the king if you want to get
this shirt that you can't get anywhere
else or maybe this Eskin or praise the
sun or meli horas feel the wrath click
the link in the description and check
them out by buying a shirt you are
directly supporting more content here on
the channel and I want to give a quick
congratulations to wolfy on Twitter for
winning our create your own seven deadly
sins character contest
wolfies winning design Milan's ax the
female demon who escaped being sealed
away inside the coffin of eternal
darkness and hid away among the fairy
clan was brought to life by ku zolani
means those fairy wings that mallanna
creates out of her demonic darkness are
just incredible definitely check out who
so many social media and show him some
love
links in the description more contest
will be held in the future so if you
want to participate be sure to follow us
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will look at the most
recent chapters in the seven deadly sins
stories so if you're not caught up to
the manga spoiler alert you have been
warned in chapter 302 we saw King and
Goethe are talking about bonds new
strengths and they mentioned that bond
is now on a whole other level after
coming back from purgatory
even though bond is no longer immortal
due to his training in purgatory he is
now even stronger than an immortal which
is a very cool concept in and of itself
to become immortal all bond had to do
was drink for
fountain of eternal youth but now due to
his hard work unwavering resolve and
courage to enter purgatory in the first
place
bond has earned the kind of power that
makes him even stronger than back when
he was immortal as the battle rages on
between bond and the demon king inside
of Mele Otis's body in the physical
world and Mele Otis's emotions and the
demon king inside meliodas a very
important piece of information is
revealed it's easy to just quickly gloss
over this on the first reading because
so much action is happening at this
point but while fighting the demon king
Mele Otis's emotions say give it up you
don't belong here
don't you think that your body in
purgatory misses you this confirms that
the demon king did not somehow fuse into
meliodas with his own body rather the
demon king is merely possessing
melioidosis body but the demon King's
own original body is still safe and
sound back in purgatory this clearly
implies that the battle we are
witnessing now may not be the final
battle after all even if the demon king
stops possessing meliodas body he will
simply go back to his own massive and
incredibly powerful original body so
even if he stops possessing meliodas
the demon king will not be defeated he
will still pose a major threat to the
sins and everyone else and this gives us
a strong possibility that there will be
another battle between Mele Otis and the
sins on the one side and the demon king
in his original body on the other
moreover the demon king tells meliodas
that even if he drives him out the fact
that he is awoken to his inner demon
lord power means that meliodas cannot
last in the mortal plane for more than
one day
Mele Oda says that that's fine as long
as he can break Elizabeth's curse and
say goodbye to her in the sins but this
again implies that the major conflict of
the story may not be over after this
battle if Mele Otis is forced to leave
the mortal plane then the story will
definitely feel incomplete since
meliodas is after all the main
protagonist of the entire series this
implies that more twists and turns may
be coming before the entire story really
does come to an end thanks to the
valiant efforts that Mele Otis's
emotions are putting up against the
demon king on the inside bond is able to
gain the upper hand on the
and King on the outside however as soon
as the demon king manages to overwhelm
melioidosis emotions the demon king
inside my horse's body regains control
of the physical battle against bond the
demon king even manages to injure bond
by piercing through his abdomen with his
fingers something that bond never would
have had to worry about back when he was
still immortal on top of that
melioidosis emotions have no way of
knowing what is actually happening on
the outside and it looks as though the
demon king has one as meliodas emotions
seem overwhelmed the sins and Elizabeth
realized that they are losing the battle
both inside among the Oates's body and
in the physical world and at this point
go thir has an idea he uses his ability
invasion to allow Elizabeth and all of
the sins except for bond to enter
meliodas his heart and reunite with
meliodas emotions the sins and Elizabeth
informally odors that bond is still out
there fighting for him and that all of
them together will be his strength this
was just such an emotional reunion
especially the brief moment between
meliodas and Elizabeth definitely gives
you the fields but only for a quick
instant because the threat posed by the
demon king is still immediate and
pressing go through explains that even
though they entered millions his heart
they cannot directly interfere in the
fight between meliodas emotions and the
demon king all they can do is encourage
meliodas and give him mental and
spiritual strength the demon king tries
to pull a begun thought on Elizabeth and
the others but after seeing his friends
and how much they all care for him
meliodas finds new strength to fight
back the demon king quickly decides that
he will sever the spiritual connection
between malleolus and his friends by
destroying his friends back in the
physical world but mile and ludo shall
vow to never let that happen
and of course bond is doing his best to
fight against the demon king out in the
physical world at this point the demon
king creates this flying ballad from
berserk looking creature called the
sighing sage the sighing sage appears to
have the power of a frickin hydrogen
bomb because it annihilates everything
in sight and it looks as if the ballot
is about to kill everyone in the
physical world bond is too busy trying
to keep up with the demon king inside
meliodas body to do anything against the
science age but just as their own is
about to be destroyed Zell drous enters
the fray and pierces the sighing sage
using the deme
Kings own power which the demon king had
granted his sons eldress as his
representative this epic battle really
is full of twists and turns and it is
happening on multiple fronts we have the
physical fight between the demon king
emilio does his body and bond we have
the internal struggle between
melioidosis emotions and the demon king
and we have this flying sighing sage
thing attacking the other sins Elizabeth
and the Archangels and then we see Zell
drous stepping in turning against his
own father and choosing to believe in
his brother meliodas instead if this was
the final battle in the seven deadly
sins it would definitely be a worthy one
and I don't think any of us could
complain I mean just thinking about
these last few arcs being animated and
shown in the anime gives me goosebumps
it's going to be absolutely amazing
however if this does turn out to be the
final battle in the series meaning that
the demon king will be defeated by the
team efforts of the sins the Archangels
Elizabeth and Zell drous there will
still be a lot of unanswered questions
first of all if the demon king simply
goes back to his original body in
purgatory won't he still be a major
threat to the world you never know what
he could be plotting behind the scenes
or when he could possess someone else
second if meliodas can only remain in
the mortal plane for less than a day
will he also be trapped somewhere and
destined to live without Elizabeth and
his friends and what about the supreme
deity is she going to play a role in the
story or are we supposed to accept that
while one godly creature ie the demon
king is the final villain the other
godly creature the supreme deity will
remain completely irrelevant and don't
even get me started on the mother of
chaos and all the mysteries surrounding
her personally I think that this
multifaceted battle as incredible as it
is won't be the final showdown in the
series I say this because it seems to me
that the true goal of meliora is the
seven deadly sins and all the heroes in
the story including the original goal
thorough rest and peace is to end the
holy wars once and for all these wars
have been causing innocent creatures to
suffer for thousands of years and the
only happy ending will be an ending
where these pointless wars between the
demons and the goddesses finally come to
an end
I predict that meliodas and Elizabeth
will achieve peace between the two clans
by taking over as the new leaders of the
demons and the goddesses
otice will become the next Demon Lord
and Elizabeth will become the next
supreme goddess and because they are in
love they will set an example for all
the other members of their clans that
they should not and must not hate each
other but in order for something like
this to happen the demon king must be
defeated completely including in his
original body back in purgatory and of
course in order for Elizabeth to bring
peace to the goddess clan she will have
to stand up against the supreme deity at
some point the supreme deity teaches
hatred towards the demon clan just like
the demon king teaches hatred towards
the goddesses so because of this I find
it difficult to believe that the holy
wars can ever be stopped if the demon
king is defeated but the supreme deity
remains untouched but these are just my
own personal thoughts obviously we won't
know for sure until the manga really
does come to an end although I hope that
will be later rather than sooner because
I have been absolutely loving the story
for the past year or so feel free to let
me know what you guys think is this the
final showdown or will there be more to
the story
also what in the world is happening with
the supreme deity what is she up to let
me know down below don't forget to
follow us on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar if you want to stay in
touch and take part in future contests
if you feel that videos like this one
provide value for you and you want to
support more you can check out our
patreon we recently revamped the whole
thing a big thank you to all the patrons
supporting us right now including our
pro hero to your patrons a 17f FDP the
one and only Gilgamesh and keelon even
donating a single dollar will give you
access to our special page and only
discord and you will see your name
appear in our videos so please if you're
interested check us out link in the
description finally a few of you have
asked about whether I will make chapter
view videos for every seven deadly sins
chapter personally i prefer making
videos based on a specific theme rather
than a single chapter so sometimes if I
feel that the chapter didn't give me
enough to go on for a video I will hold
off on making it until the next chapter
comes out however if you do want to
discuss every individual chapter you can
follow us on Twitch at twitch TV slash
anime uproar every Wednesday around 5
p.m. Eastern Standard Time we will be
streaming a live discussion and Q&A
about that week's chapter so if that's
something you'd like to be a part of
follow us on Twitch link in the
description as always thank you guys so
much for
Ching and until next time see us space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]